en vous écoutant je me pose la question
de quelle réforme parlez vous je pense
qu'on ne peut pas parler de casse du
service public ou de désengagement de
l'état au moment où nous nous apprêtons
à investir plus qu'on ne l'a jamais fait
qu'est ce que vous avez fait quand vous
étiez aux responsabilités elisabeth
bornes et la nouvelle chef du
gouvernement les sénateurs la
connaissent bien ils ont eu affaire à
elle en tant que ministre et ça a été
parfois un peu tendu
au début du premier quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro elisabeth bornes
ministre des transports elle mène la
réforme de la sncf qui ouvre le secteur
ferroviaire à la concurrence et lors du
débat au sénat elle doit faire face à
l'opposition de la gauche et notamment
des communistes qui font un coup d'éclat
dans l'hémicycle il porte le gilet
orange des cheminots et brandissent des
pancartes de protestation c'est un
projet porteur d'un choix de société le
choix d'une société où l'argent ici
nouveau précepte la rentabilité la
productivité prennent le pas sur les
idées même du service public et de
l'intérêt général je pense qu'on ne peut
pas parler de casse du service public ou
de désengagement de l'état au moment où
nous nous apprêtons à investir plus
qu'on ne l'a jamais fait dans le système
ferroviaire après les jets les oranges
des cheminots place au général à la fin
de l'année 2018 une révolte contre la
hausse des taxes sur les carburants
la ministre des transports et isabelle
borne est en première ligne et elle doit
répondre aux critiques de l'opposition
sur la gestion de cette crise par le
gouvernement ce qui est en train de se
passer dans notre pays
c'est une totale incompréhension de la
part du gouvernement vis-à-vis de la
colère des français nous sommes devant
une situation intolérable
intolérable qu'est ce qui a été fait par
le passé
la politique du tout tgv qui abandonner
des pans entiers de notre territoire
avec des réseaux qui se dégrade à l'été
2010 9 elisabeth bande prend du galon
elle est nommée ministre de la
transition écologique et un an plus tard
elle nous a acté la fermeture de la
centrale nucléaire de fessenheim prévue
de longue date est cette fois ci c'est
la majorité de droite du sénat qui monte
au créneau la facture énergétique des
français et des entreprises françaises
l'invs a largement progressé vous
pénalisez très fortement tout un bassin
d'emploi l'arrêt de fessenheim incarne
l'écologie de responsabilité porté par
le président de la république le
gouvernement et la majorité depuis 2010
et on rappelle que désormais la première
ministre elisabeth bornes d'oeuvre
orchestré le virage des manuels macron
en faveur du nucléaire avec cette
décision prise à la toute fin de son
premier quinquennat de construire de
nouveaux réacteurs dernier coup d'oeil
dans le rétro on finit par une réforme
impopulaire qu'elisabeth borgne a mené
l'an dernier en tant que ministre du
travail la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui touche au mode de calcul de
l'allocation des demandeurs d'emploi
certains y perdre au change et forcément
la gauche est vent debout contre cette
réforme c'est sûr les plus fragiles et
précaires que vous faites poser vos
objectifs d'économies en diminuant leurs
droits en estimant qu'ils font le choix
du chômage c'est faux ils le subissent
cette réforme elle repose sur deux
principes lutter contre la précarité et
al tur et plus d'équité dans le calcul
des allocations chômage est maintenant à
matignon les abeilles bornes doit porter
une autre réforme impopulaire la réforme
des retraites avec le recul de l'âge de
départ à 65 ans et là encore le débat au
parlement s'annonce mouvementée
[Musique]